Buckminster Fuller was comprehensive
anticipatory design scientist by his own
definition what exactly that meant and
how he defined it changed constantly
over the course of his lifetime as he
sought to make the world work for a
hundred percent of humanity as he
described it what he wanted to do was to
figure out what all of the problems were
within the world in his time and how
those problems might evolve over time
and what sort of technologies might be
available that could address those
problems in a way that would make the
world sustainable at every level from
the environment as a whole to individual
lives and the ability of individuals in
society to thrive he often overshot as
far as his ideas were concerned in terms
of coming up with inventions that were
improbable at best and required
materials required mechanisms that would
take a very long time to come about that
only in our own world in our own time
have become feasible but in so doing he
said a sort of a template I believe for
thinking comprehensively and thinking in
terms of the patterns that exist between
people and problems and the ways in
which solutions need to come from far
enough in the future to be able to
genuinely address those problems
holistically and to be able to do so in
time and through time Buckminster Fuller
had many ways over his lifetime that he
applied his key invention the one for
which he's best known the geodesic dome
possibly his most unexpected use of the
dome was initially as an outdoor
planetarium in which you would be able
to see your relationship to the planet
by
looking out at the stars through cutouts
of the continents but which became as he
became more ambitious a globe that would
be 200 feet in diameter placed in the
East River in view of the United Nations
that would be completely clad and
lighting that would allow for
visualizations of everything from
climate to where warfare was taking
place to global migration patterns and
the idea was this sort of massive
visualization that the United Nations
could use in order to be able to
understand what was happening in the
world and the impact of decisions being
made within the UN this never happened
he lobbied for it for decades and it was
never feasible largely because there
were not the sort of data streams that
would have been required and also
because he was asking for an enormous
amount of money for a very large and
unwieldy structure to be placed in the
East River today it is incredibly easy
to imagine how those data streams might
be drawn from sensor networks that are
ubiquitous throughout the world making
use of the Internet one might initially
dismiss the idea of the gia scope as
pointless given that everybody on their
computer or on their smartphone is able
to see any sort of visualization we live
in a culture that is very much oriented
toward these visualizations yet the
problem is that each of us does so in a
way that is very much a matter of how we
navigate that global set of patterns
that global set of that that global set
of data that comes through these sensor
networks as a result we end up each of
us seeing the world in our own way and
not really being able to communicate
with each other the idea that gia scope
was quite the contrary to have a commons
by which everyone could come together as
fuller envisioned it in his time that
body being the United Nations but today
given the ease with which we could
Eve what the gia scope did both in terms
of data feed and also in terms of
visualization of that data it becomes
something that could happen in any city
and that I believe needs to happen in
every city what I foresee is a future in
which every city has what I call a data
Park which is a park that is at scale
the shape and contour of the city itself
a public space during the daytime
covered in grass where people go and do
what you would do in a park but at night
where the ground is illuminated with
colored LEDs all of which are networked
in a way that it becomes possible to
visualize the data of the city
microclimates and how they interact
energy usage and how that may correlate
with a possibility of harvesting energy
through solar and other alternate energy
sources gentrification all of these
issues that we tend only to see through
the narrow confines of what interests us
and our own beliefs by way of our own
computer or smartphone for this to be a
public space in which people can come
together and see that data for their
city while simultaneously seeing a
microt seeing a geo scope in miniature
that map's the same data for the entire
planet and therefore creates
interrelationship between the place in
which you live and the planet as a whole
to me this this data Park becomes a way
in which to take the spirit of
Buckminster Fuller and this idea that we
need to understand the world through
pattern recognition but it has to happen
collectively in order for collective
action to take place